we're gonna do a draft today big cat of
mvp candidates other than quarterbacks
so it can be anyone you want other than
a quarterback the most likely mvp
candidates i've got the trivia question
if you get it right you get the first
pick there are five quarterbacks that
have thrown a touchdown pass for both
the 49ers and the chiefs five of them
touchdown pass for the 49ers and the
chiefs name three
alex smith joe montana steve deberg
steve bono elvis gerbach
oh god that nut
no one told me that same text message i
did
absolutely not absolutely not mike
actually you don't listen to part of my
take because we talked about it on
wednesday's show
it is insane
that the 49ers there was a stretch i
think it was three decades long where
the 49ers the chiefs did not win a
football game with a quarterback they
drafted yet they won like 150 games with
san francisco 49er drafted quarterbacks
and also it's a little shout out to
brodie croyle who the 40 the the chiefs
did draft and went 0-10
in his starts for the chiefs so the
history between these two franchises and
the quarterbacks is very weird very odd
and i knew that answer
so i will say this i didn't listen to
wednesday's pardon my take and whoever
writes the trivia questions didn't
listen either or maybe they did maybe
they maybe maybe i'm the one who's on
the wrong side of this grift all right
you get the first pick all right uh it
is a crazy stat though it's very fun to
go down that rabbit hole uh
okay my first pick is gonna be easy one
it's raheem uh mostert he is definitely
the far and away if you're talking about
uh
mvp candidates that aren't quarterbacks
he's going to be the guy because if the
49ers win it's going to be a lot because
of what he does running the ball if he
puts in a game like he did obviously 220
yards was out of this world good but if
you get somewhere around 130
maybe a score or two and jimmy garoppolo
only passes the ball 15 times he's gonna
be a surefire mvp
if the 49ers win this game so that's the
easy number one pick that already has
won me the draft
no i don't well you won the draft
because the trivia question was rigged
i'm going with george kittle because of
the credit he'll get for blocking
the overall football vibe that he has
the name recognition the voters like him
and if they throw the ball at all he's
going to get his catches he's going to
get his yards and they've got some plays
in the playbook where it can pop wide
open and and he's just he's got that
tenacity he's got that that vibe that
personality that plays on a huge stage
and there's gonna be a lot of casual
football fans just fall in love with the
guy next week and i just think he's
going to be in the front of the minds of
the voters where they're going to pay
attention to his blocking
and if he has any reasonable stats gets
a touchdown 75 or more yards receiving
and the 49ers win unless mostar has
another gigantic game kittle's gonna get
some votes mike uh i love i love george
kittle i love him uh and he's great to
watch fun to watch fun guy he's great
for football but let me ask you a
question trivia question for you mike
who was the last
super bowl mvp that won super bowl mvp
because of blocking
do you have the answer no i but he's no
no the answer is no but but he's no one
but he's gonna get credit here's the
thing because we give him so much credit
for his blocking the people who cast the
ballots will be thinking well you know
his numbers aren't great in the passing
game he only had 75 yards in a touchdown
but he's a hell of a blocker you know
what happens presents
do you know what happens if he blocks
well
where he mostly gets the mvp
yeah but tevin coleman's going to be
healthy maybe matt breita gets the ball
maybe they maybe they don't overdo it
with raheem mostert this time around
it's rare for them to go that that all
in with one guy okay uh
what the hell was i supposed to do i won
the draft
again just gonna admit i take it
if you have a better point
if you have a better point go ahead and
make it make make your next pick take
care and make a better point no ah
yeah i'll take kittle i'll make a better
point
uh this is going to be
the the week of george kittle greg
kittle if we can say his name correctly
because he's the breakout star of the
super bowl he's going to be on part of
my take and harry potter said all that
he is going to be the guy that
everyone's talking about it's going to
be the travis kelsey george kittle thing
and i think that he'll be in the front
of the minds of all the voters when
they're casting that ballot on sunday
night that's exactly what i just said
all right my next exactly what i said my
next pick is gonna be tyrone matthew i'm
gonna i'm gonna take the honey badger
because he is a well-known name if he
can get an interception if you know the
the 49ers are going to run it as much as
we think they are and he's got to be you
know coming downhill getting a bunch of
tackles i think he is uh going to be the
guy non-qb guy that can win this mvp
because of how well known he is and
because of the ability he's gonna have
to make a lot of plays in this game for
the chiefs to be to win this game the
chiefs to be good in this game so i
think he is uh my number two pick it's
easy he's the number two pick i'm
dominating this draft
eric kendricks is the right guy in the
right place at the right time defender
in the viking system and he could have
had three interceptions of jimmy
garoppolo two weeks ago tyron matthew is
clearly the right guy in the right place
at the right time member of the chief's
defense he you never know where he's
gonna be you never know where he's gonna
pop up he's kind of like troy palamallo
i always thought quarterbacks held onto
the ball a little bit longer than they
wanted to because you had to be damn
sure that troy palamala was going to pop
up and jump the ball and grab the ball
when you throw it and i think matthew
has that quality and i think if jimmy
garoppolo is going to turn the ball over
it's going to be to tyrant matthew so
you took my second pick uh
if
so yeah i could have taken him first i
guess i could have taken him instead of
greg kittle i'll take nick bosa as my
second pick and uh this this one's
simple because if the if the 49ers win
at some point somebody's gonna have to
make a play on patrick mahomes
somebody's got to sack him and of any of
the guys on that front four nick bose is
the one who can do it and nick bose is
going to get the attention he's got the
name recognition if they have a big game
out of that front four he's gonna get
the credit for it and he's got the
potential to be the mvp
okay decent pick decent pick i'll go
with my last pick i'm gonna say travis
kelsey and here's the reason behind it
obviously if you're gonna pick a wide
receiver or a tight end you have to say
to yourself what is the way that the the
they can win the mvp and the quarterback
cannot because as we've seen throughout
super bowl history they're always going
to give votes to the quarterback the
quarterback is almost the implied winner
of the super bowl unless he really
screws something up or you know like
peyton manning von miller wins that
because their defense showed out
if
the chiefs if the chiefs big deep
threats are kept you know contained here
and patrick mahomes doesn't have
the eye-popping yardage that he can get
if he hits miko hardman if he hits
tyreek hill if he hits sammy watkins
deep if it's more of a
let's get 15 plays drive where the the
49ers are saying let's let patrick
mahomes have to march them down the
field never giving them the over-the-top
stuff i think travis kelsey has a chance
to win mvp if he can get to that 11-12
catch radi you know you know area and
patrick mahomes maybe only has
275 yards and half of them are travis
kelsey i think he is the most likely guy
on the chiefs to win the mvp on the
offensive side of the ball not named
patrick mahomes
yeah you know i i agree with you there
um and and i was thinking tyrique
would the voters vote for what what does
it take for tyrone what does it take
what does it take what can't happen
it cannot happen because if tyree kill
has has huge numbers patrick holmes has
huge numbers the only way that an
offensive player not named patrick
holmes on the chiefs can win if it's if
if the 49ers make them dink and dunk and
go these like 15 play drives and they
have to eat you know slowly get down the
field and and travis kelsey becomes that
like possession receiver in the middle
of the field and gets hit a bunch and
catches a bunch and has a heroic effort
that's how it can happen
like julian edelman last year right
simple right
right all right uh i'm i'm filibustering
here i got to come up with one uh
dominated you just just concede roll
over let me sniff your belly we're at
the dog park i beat you
are you done yeah go ahead i'm gonna go
robbie gold you know why you know i'm
going robbie gold because no kicker has
ever won
mvp
of the super bowl so they're due right
and i could see a scenario where nobody
nobody has stats that just jump off the
page how many field goals does it take
what's your guy pft commenter always say
three and a half field goals over under
what if robbie gold hits four field
goals and nobody else has any huge
numbers that justify him being the mvp
maybe maybe the time has come for a
kicker and maybe it will be robbie gold
who caps off a season where he re-signs
after acrimonious negotiations with the
49ers he comes back and he bangs four
field goals and nobody else has great
numbers and they give robbie gold the
mvp how about that mark mosley was the
nfl mvp in 1983 the time has come for a
kicker to be the mvp of the super bowl
robbie gold
bear for life like anybody else bear for
life wanted to be a bear this year oh
superman and that
that's why i did it to stick it to you
okay it was all subliminal i forgot
about that i have an obvious one that
you missed and i i gave you a little
mystery we already did three rounds i
know but i'm let's just throw an extra
one on in there because that's how bad
i'm dominant i'm gonna run up the score
on you an obvious one that you missed
when we were talking about chiefs
offensive weapons i gave you a little
misdirection i said how could anyone on
the chiefs not name patrick mahomes on
the offensive side of the ball win mvp
mike you fell for my trap how do you not
put miko hardman in there as a kick
returner as a punt returner if you
return one or two kicks for a touchdown
you're going to win mvp so there you go
that is more likely than robbie gold
kicking six uh field goals and winning
mvp that way so i not only beat you with
my three picks i beat you with my fourth
pick this folks has been a bloodbath i'm
sorry i hope people they're just waking
up they turn on the tv they see what i
just did to mike florio and they're
saying stop stop he's had enough please
stop we don't hate mike florio we take
back everything we said mean about him
yesterday stop stop stop and then we
land here so america you're welcome i've
i've killed the bad guy
you know at times like this i just shut
up and let you burn yourself out and
fade into bolivian
we're gonna take a break bolivian folks
bolivians look it up uh quick break
we'll wrap up this friday edition of pft
live but first let's wrap up the draft
big cats non-quarterback mvp candidates
for the super bowl raheem mostert tyrant
matthew travis kelsey i've got george
kittle nick bosa robbie gold big cat
threw me cole hardman onto it at the end
because he felt like it violating the
rules of the draft as he often does
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports